et on dirait que tu es jérôme marty
médecin président du syndicat ufm l
union française pour une médecine libre
bonjour le port du masque est désormais
obligatoire donc dans toutes les grandes
villes françaises paris et marseille
aussi strasbourg on vient de l'apprendre
ce mâtin prévention a justifié ou
alarmisme démesurée à la remise de
démesure et probablement oui on voit
bien qu'on met en place un certain
nombre de mesures qui n'ont aucune base
scientifique faut être très clair
pourquoi on porte le masque on porte le
masque pour protéger les autres qui ont
potez quand on est seul dans la rue et
qu'on porte le masque personnes ont
peut-être personne en ironie seuil
les seuls moments où il faut porter le
masque que les seuls moments et il est
seul basé soit des véritablement sur des
faits scientifiques ce sont les lieux
clos où il ya des croisés de populations
parce qu'on sait qu'il ya là un vrai
risque à ce moment-là de contamination
de masse
et puis les moments où on se trouve en
concentration populationnelle les uns
contre les autres ou on peut transmettre
le virus soit nous sommes quelques
soient les postulants dessus tout le
reste ce sont des peurs ou des
protections politiques puisque l'effet
sanitaires et comment est ce que vous
réagissez justement rétropédalage
politique sur finalement la non
obligation de port de masques pour les
joggeurs et cyclistes à paris est-ce
qu'il faut y voir un manque de
concertation entre la mairie de paris et
la préfecture et le gouvernement
mais déjà je la salue parce que vous
savez combien il est difficile pour un
politique d'avouer cette fronde est donc
déjà je la salue c'est faire preuve de
sagesse que de revenir en arrière je
crois qu'il faut que l'on garde la tête
froide par rapport à cette infection des
reins ce virus qui va nous accompagner
malheureusement pendant des mois et des
mois qui va impacter nos vies pendant
des mois et des mois et parce que nous
allons devoir organiser nos vies par
rapport à ce virus il faut que en
organiserait les choses de façon à ce
que le nez des plages de liberté des
lieux où l'on retrouve un peu le vide
avant de façon à ce qu'on puisse un peu
en quelque sorte respirer parce que
sinon on va se porter un lieu une
résistance bien normal par rapport à
cela parce que les gens ne comprendront
pas pourquoi leur demandent de porter
les masques dans des lieux où
manifestement sentir arrière la mairie
de paris se pose maintenant la question
du port du masque obligatoire ou non
pour les fumeurs est ce qu'il peut y
avoir une
belle reculade et si oui comment
expliquer que le port du masque devient
aussi politique
vous savez aujourd'hui maire est
responsable de tout sur tout donc il est
bien légitime que ceux-ci se protège
aussi par rapport aux risques de
diffusion d'une épidémie mais on ne peut
pas demander non plus loin possible
c'est à dire on ne peut pas demander aux
gens de ne plus manger un sandwich dans
la rue de ne plus faire un certain
nombre d'activités comme fluide siret
même si en tant que médecin vous ne me
ferez pas dire que fumer c'est bien mais
on n'arrête pas le nom fait pas arrêté
de fumer avec des obligations c'est pas
comme ça que ça fonctionne
encore une fois le port du masque est
utile quand elle est en concentration de
population les uns contre les autres ou
quand on est un lieu clos et qu'est ce
que vous répondez
qu'est ce que vous répondez aux
personnes qui ne veulent pas porter le
masque mais on ne répondrai simplement
que le virus est là que tous les jours
nous avons de plus en plus de
contamination que si forte heureusement
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas
d'augmentation très visible des cas de
réanimation ou d'hospitalisation c'est
précisément parce que on a mis en place
tout un tas de mesures de protection qui
sont respectés qu'elles se sont étendus
le port du masque un lieu clos le
produit est un transport en commun
notamment que dans les hôpitaux et les
cliniques également les personnels se
protège et peut donc le virus ne diffuse
pas mais encore une fois on porte le
masque pour protéger l'autre toutes les
preuves de l'intérêt du port de masques
ont été maintes fois démontré les pays
qui ont arrêté carrément arrêter la
diffusion de l'épidémie ce sont les pays
que mis en oeuvre le port du masque dans
la population le plus tôt
mais encore faut-il ne pas faire
n'importe quoi et d'obliger le portait
même quand les gens sont peu sociables
et selon l' oms les enfants âgés de 12
ans devrait porter un masque dans les
mêmes conditions que les adultes pour
lutter contre la pandémie votre avis oui
bien sûr vous savez qu'on a on a signé
des tribunes pour le masquer un lieu
clos depuis pour le masquer si en classe
alors c'est vrai que ça paraît être
extrêmement violent mais ce que l'on
sait c'est que quand vous avez 30 élèves
dans une même classe pendant plusieurs
heures
si vous avez quelques élèves qui sont
excrétés du virus au bout d'un temps
vous avez un nuage dire allez donc vous
avez le risque de contaminer tous les
élèves qui lie à entoure
mais ni vont porter cette infection
ensuite dans leur domicile peut être
vers leurs parents ou leurs grands
parents
donc il faut porter le masque dans les
écoles probablement d'ailleurs à partir
des ciseaux même si ça paraît très
violente de ça évidemment non on ne peut
pas c'est très difficile vous pas ce que
l'on demande c'est que l'honneur les
classes il faut changer l'air des
classes très régulièrement et puis sans
doute aussi qu'on ne mobilise pas
l'ensemble des élèves de classe en
classe mais que ce sont plutôt les
professeurs qui déplace dernière
question
611 si 6111 nouveaux cas exactement de
coronavirus en 24 heures pardon c'est un
record depuis le décompte final
quels sont vos retours à vous sur le
terrain
est ce que vous comptez constaté un réel
rebond depuis l'épidémie soit il admis
vraiment inquiet oui la réponse est oui
vous savez dans ma région je suis sur la
région toulousaine on en voyait très
puce comme résorbe et rien que hier et
avant-hier j'ai eu plus de huit cas de
patients qui sont venus me voir parce
qu'ils avaient été en contact direct
avec des jeunes testés positifs donc le
virus circule il ya aucun problème et
plus on va avoir deux jambes contaminés
plus on a de risques qu'ils s'installent
des corridors entre la population peu à
risque que sont les jeunes et la
population plus à risque sont les gens
agit donc si nous ne voulons pas
reconnaître une augmentation très forte
des hospitalisations et malheureusement
des réanimations avec des drames à la
clé
nous devons évidemment respecter les
mesures barrières merci j'ai remarqué
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin et
président du syndicat unef mails l'union
française pour une médecine libre